There was a mathematician named Klein
who thought Möbius bands are divine. Said
he, if you glue the edges of two you get
the weird bottle like mine.
You're probably familiar with a Möbius
band. It's the special shape where, if you
run your finger on the surface you start
here on the outside you're running it
along the surface, and magically you're
ending up on the other side. So we
have been able to go from one side of
the surface to the other without
actually stepping over the edge; we just
did it by going once around the loop. So
if we were to start spreading paint
from here and we just paint and paint
and paint that surface, we'll actually
end up painting everything. And so this
is called a single sided surface, or
mathematicians also call it and
non-orientable surface. Just one face, one
paint colour needed to paint everything.
Now, this particular surface has an edge.
So here is an edge, let's see. If we go
along this particular edge, I'm running
around here I'm going through my hand,
I'm on the bottom side now, and I'm going
through the bottom of the edge and
suddenly I come back up again.
So it's only
a single edge but the edge actually goes
twice around that loop. So we have a
single sided surface, with a single edge.
Now the single sided surface is pretty
intriguing; we got from one side of the
surface to the other without having to
drill through the surface, or without
having to step across the edge. Is it
possible to make a single sided surface
that has no edges - that's kind of closed?
Just like a sphere has no edges, right,
it's a closed surface. But in a sphere to
get from the inside to the outside
you clearly have to drill through the
surface. So can we make a single sided
surface that has no edges? That you could
step over? And where it seems impossible
to get from one side to the other. You
can - it's called a Klein bottle.
This is a
Klein bottle. Now, how this is- what we
said before apply, is this really single
sided? Assume that you're an ant and now
the ant is walking on the outside of the
bulb and getting to the outside of the
handle, walking around the outside of the
handle, walking on the outside of the
handle and penetrating through the wall
but staying on the outside of the
handle on this inner part. And you now, if
you imagine that you're on the outside
of this inner handle you're now inside
this bulb. So as you walk around the
bottom you're still on the inside, and you
can walk all around the inside of this
bulb. You can then continue on the inside
of the bulb walking into the inside of
the handle, now you're walking on the
inside of the tunnel all the way around
the loop. You're staying on the inside of
the handle and you're coming out. And
you're
back on the outside again. So it is
indeed possible to get from one side of
the glass surface to the other.
(Brady: But didn't you pass-
like you didn't drill a)
(hole but wouldn't you have needed to)
(drill a-)
- Ahh you caught me,
okay, unfortunately there are no Klein
bottles that have no so-called self
intersections. The Klein bottle really is
a mathematical construct that you could
do in four dimensional space without any
intersections. Any kind of Klein bottle
that you want to do in three-dimensional
space does indeed have some kind of
penetration. Now the rule for
mathematicians is: where two surfaces
like that the, branches go through one
another, they're completely unaware and
oblivious that they're branching. You're
basically allowed to stay on your
surface; you cannot step from one to the
other. But of course implicitly
as you go on this surface through the
other one you basically have gone from
one side to the other and that's why the
Klein bottle works in three
dimensional space.
(Brady: So in the rules of mathematics the)
(ant doesn't need a drill to get
through here?)
It doesn't even know that there is this
other surface coming through. It just
walks basically on that surface and it
sees no no other surface except the one
that it's walking on. And so that's how
it gets magically from one side to the
other. So that is kind of the simplest
form of a Klein bottle, it is made by
Cliff Stoll of ACME Klein bottles in
Berkeley. And he has an amazing amount of
different Klein bottles you can get
from him, you know, just go to his website
ACME Klein bottles. And for instance, you
know what the stein is? The kind of thing
they have in your Hofbräu house at the
Oktoberfest?
- (Brady: Oh I love the Hofbräu house!)
There is your stein except
it's a small stein. But it's a special
stein, it's a Klein stein. If you look
closely down here you can see it seems
to have a double wall, and indeed it does
have a double wall.
So now if you pour a liquid up on top
inside, and then you find that there's a
hole here that goes from the inner
volume into the handle. And so by the
time the liquid reaches that little hole
and runs down the handle it will pour
into the interstitial space between the
inner and the outer cylinder, and it fills
the outer space. So you realise the
potential; you basically fill in coffee
into the outside and you fill in brandy
on the inside and you're sitting happily
in your office, and when your boss comes
by you swear that you're drinking
coffee but you're enjoying yourself very
much with what's on the inner part of it.
So this is a Klein stein. Topologically
it is exactly like this Klein bottle
just has a different shape, you know
there's this extra bulb kind of stuffed
in, but other than that it's exactly the
same deal. You know you can walk
basically on one surface and then go
around the handle, make this unofficial
kind of transition through the glass
surface and get essentially from one
side to the other.
So still a Klein bottle, it's still a
single sided surface that has no edges
per se. So here is my Klein stein and we
want to see what happens when we pour a
liquid into it, have a little bit of
coffee. And we start to fill in and at
the beginning everything is normal and
nothing special happens. So now, so far
everything is just as it would be in an
ordinary stein. But now as we pour in
more liquid see what happens when you
get to the handle - oh no it starts to run
down the handle here, okay. So now we have
a trapped air volume up here, right? And
it's kind of hard to now fill it without
kind of you know shaking a little bit
and let's try and get the air bubbles
out. So that's kind of a problem, so maybe
we already filled too much so what we
should do is pour out a little bit more.
And now that we have more flexibility
we can get- so it's a little bit hard to
set up your your coffee cup on the
outside with then the brandy on the
inside as you as you can see but so
gradually we're getting a higher filling
level here on the outside. A Klein
bottle is made from two Möbius bands.
Remember, a Möbius band is a single sided
surface but it has that one edge. Now, if
you take two Möbius bands, a red one and
a green one, and they both have just
one edge. And now you're starting to fuse
those edges together and you kind of
zipper them along those edges right? What
d'you get? Well all the edges have
disappeared, it's like taking two disks
right and the two disks have two edges and
you glue the two disks together, they
form a sphere. But if you do that here,
yes we get rid of all the edges, but it's
still single sided because each piece
itself was single side in the first place.
So we get a single sided surface that
has no edges; actually we get a Klein
bottle. Here is something that also Cliff
Stoll made: well it looks sort of like a
Klein bottle. So here is the bulge,
right, and here is that handle, And here
is that kind of transition where the
handle essentially goes through that
surface and goes inside that bulb. Now
the beauty of this object is that
somewhere here is a zipper. Now if I can
find the beginning of the zipper - there
it is - so now we can open that zipper,
that's like cutting the Klein bottle
into two parts. So I'm zipping open.
You have to go twice around the loop
remember, that these loops here on the
Möbius band they go twice around. So
basically I have to zip twice around
here. See, now I'm coming on my second
pass here; and then it falls apart. Oh my
God, what have I got here?
I have this band right? And the band
somehow looks twisted. And yes of course
it varies in width, it starts out narrow
and it gets through the white part which
then forms the bulb; but there's clearly
a twist of 180 degree right about here,
so this is a Möbius band.
And the other half is essentially its
mirror image. So, here again is a Möbius
band; and we have seen the two together
essentially form the Klein bottle. So
that shows how a Klein bottle is formed
from two Möbius Bands. Here again is an
ordinary-looking kind of Klein bottle,
okay, I made the bulb a little narrower
and I put more emphasis basically on the
handle here. And you can see that's the
place where the handle goes back into
the bulb. I think that's kind of the way
these two things look. Now if you
look at the handle you can see that the
the lines here in the handle are
essentially twisted. So in glass you
cannot see that where it's twisted or
not but if you put this structure on
there you can actually give it a twist;
I put the twist of a full turn of
360 degrees. And then I cut it apart
along a line, not like the other Klein
bottle which I had split simply smack
down the symmetry plane, but I essentially
cut it down along one of those twisted
spiral things and look what happens; I
basically get two of those thingys
interlocking now and each one
individually is essentially a Möbius
ban. You can see it's a band that
starts here, it warps around and then it
makes a 180 degree flip up here. So
here again is another way of
essentially turning a Klein bottle into
two Möbius bands, but because of the
twists that I put into the handle, now
the two Möbius bands are actually
intertwined. So most people who have
heard about Klein bottles probably have
seen a picture of that, that's the most
familiar one. But actually mathematicians
tell you there's more than just one
Klein bottle and this is also a Klein
bottle. At first glance it looks kind of
weird and jumbled, you know
what's going on?
Well, what's going on is that we make
ourselves a tube, like we have here, but
the tube now is not having a circular
cross-section
but we make ourselves a tube that has a
figure-eight cross-section like that. And
you can see if we had to do that and you
colour it then if you paint red on the
one half of this figure eight the red
would go through that junction and be on
the inside of the other loop; and then
green would be on the outside here and
green would be on the other side. So if
we take this two colour tube and we flip
it around in a big circle and showing it
back to itself, red goes to red green
goes to green, it still would be a
torus; just an ordinary torus. But if you
take this figure eight and we rotate it
180 degrees and then join it back to
itself, well the red lobe joins with the
green lobe, the green lobe joins with the
red lobe. And we have the same situation
we had before that if you start painting
and just paint and paint, before you know
it you have painted everything. So we're
back to a single sided surface; that's
exactly what we have here. So if you
focus in on that part you can see
essentially this figure eight
cross-section which I mentioned before.
And I very carefully made sure that
right here at the intersection line, if
you look at the lines that come from one
side they're going through that
cross-section without touching the other
ones. Again, that confirms that
mathematical notion that there where
surfaces cross you cannot step from one
to the other, they're kind of oblivious
of one from the other okay? So this is
our figure right cross section. Now we're
swinging this figure eight cross
section around the loop, and while doing
so we must make sure we have an odd
number of flips. We could get, you know, a
single flip from here going once around,
a single 180 degree flip but in
this case I actually have elected to do
three flips. So here it is in that
configuration, it flips and here again
it's facing up to you it flips once more
to here, and then once more to here; so
three times 180 degree flip - also make
sure that one of those lobes when you
come around you're on the other lobe. And
that makes it into a single sided
surface and that again is a Klein
bottle; there are no edges, it's single
sided. It happens to same kind of
connectivity as this particular
Klein bottle.
- (Brady: It seems very different from
that one.)
It is quite different.
And particularly the
mathematicians in this case when you ask
them why are they different, they say
because there's no way that you can
smoothly transform this object into that
object. They have a fancy name, they call
something a regular homotopy if it is
possible, to by only smoothly deforming
thing, never ever have any sharp creases,
never ever doing this kind of thing
where you have a loop and then you just
kind of get rid of that loop - that's not
allowed. As long as you smoothly deform
things, no matter how much you stretch
and compress that's a regular homotopy.
And two things are sort of equal or in the
same regular homotopy class if you
can transform them. You cannot transform
that into this, that's why these Klein
bottles are different. Now if you look at
this, it has clearly a handedness to it.
It sort of rotates- in this
case I think if
you go forward it rotates
counterclockwise as you as you kind of
smoothly go forward, you can see that
cross-section rotating sort of
counter clockwise, okay?
The mirror image of that is in a
different regular homotopy class. You
cannot transform that into its mirror
image.
The reason is basically you cannot
take a Möbius band and smoothly
transform it into its mirror image, it
has a handedness built-in. And
remember, Klein bottles are built from two
Möbius bands. Turns out the regular Klein
bottle here is built from one
right-handed, one left-handed Möbius band;
we've seen that before, we had those two
Möbius bands and when they fell apart
they were mirror images, a right one and
a left one. So here, if you have
something that is a figure eight that
twists right handed, you cut it apart in
the middle it essentially composes into
two right-handed Möbius bands. The other
one falls into two left-handed Möbius
bands, okay? So we already have three
different regular homotopies for Klein
bottles. Three different Klein bottles.
Well, that was known in a paper going
back to about 30 years by Hass
and Hughes; and they make one more
observation. They say if you essentially
put a structure like this coordinate
grid we have or some colour on the
surface, then there are four different
Klein bottles. And that really intrigued
me. So I I set out, you know, several
months of my life to find- I want to
find that fourth Klein bottle. Now that
mathematical paper was above my horizon,
I couldn't follow all the logics that
had to do is group theory and symmetry and
observation and
the like - I wanted to make
a really nice picture, figure out what's
going on here. And in that process I came
up with other interesting Klein bottles.
So here, what is this? Well it's again a
figure 8 loop, now it forms a trefoil
knot as we've seen before. Actually it is
really no different from that one.
Because remember topologists allow you
to smoothly pass surfaces through one
another; in particular a knot makes no
sense to a topologist because you have
two strands and, you know, they pass right
through one another. So you could open
this trefoil knot into just a simple
loop and it would then be simply a
triply twisted figure-eight loop just
like this one.
So this - nothing new, it just belongs to
that one.
Searching further for that fourth Klein
bottle I came up with this wonderful
contraption. I thought this was really
cool because it's sort of like this
thing, only there's of two of them. I call
this the inverted sock Klein bottle
because at the end the mouth looks like
the part of an inverted sock. And this is
like the inverted double sock, right?
And I
thought surely that this is different
and this must be, you know, the new Klein
bottle. Well to make a long story short
it isn't. The main reason actually turned
out that this is not its own mirror
image. If I make a mirror image then
it is clearly different, and if you
analyse this and you
cut it apart into Möbius
strips you find out it's falling apart
into two identical Möbius strips,
okay? And so again we have the same
situation; we get essentially a
right hand left-handed version. So the
logic says if this were something new I
get not just one new thing I get two new
things; a right hand left handed version.
But that paper clearly proves they're
only four Klein bottles not five, so this
must be something known. And since it
fell apart into two identical Möbius
bands it really is in disguise that same
thing- object again. So that was not it.
Then I came across this one. This is
indeed another special Klein bottle,
it's due to Lawson who proved that this
is the minimum energy Klein bottle. In
some sense nature would prefer that, it's
like a soap film. Soap films try to take
on the shape that minimises the surface
area, minimises the built in energy
that's in in the surface. And so if
similarly we were to look at this
surface and there is bending energy
required to bend it and the more you
bend it the more energy you require;
typically the bending energy of a thin
sheet of metal goes with the square of
curvature. And so if you integrate square
of curvature over this surface and
compared this to any other Klein bottle
then this one has the lowest possible
energy. I thought that is pretty cool,
maybe that is number four - but again you
can obviously tell by looking at it that
this thing seems to have some chirality
again, so it's not its own mirror image.
So again, if this were new there would be
two of them; you analyse how it breaks
apart in Möbius bands and you find it
breaks apart into identical Möbius
bands so again we're back on that same
heap. Okay, nothing new yet, okay? Phew.
Ah! Now here's an interesting shape. It
looks like a special Klein bottle, it has
two inverted sock mouths, okay?
(Brady: That looks like a roller coaster
or something)
(that should be at Disneyland)
- Ah it looks fantastic,
right? Now it turns out it's not even a
Klein bottle. Because here is what
happens, if you start here on the outside
and you go around and you get to the
inside at this mouth,
and you go around the inside of the
handle, inside of the handle, inside of
the handle and you're coming out here
and you're back where you were.
This actually
is two-sided, you could clearly- you know
paint it with one colour on one side and
this the other - so it's just a torus.
It's a weird torus, you know that kind
of self intersects and does weird things;
it's not a Klein bottle. So, you have to
be very careful when you look at these
things to make sure whether you have a
Klein bottle or whether it's actually a
two sided surface. Sometimes that's not
a recipe that works quite simply, but
if you have an even number of these kind
of surface inversion mouths then it's
just a torus. If you have an odd number
then it's very likely a Klein bottle. So,
what is this? Is this a Klein bottle?
(Brady: That's a monster.)
- It's a Klein knot-tle I call it. A
knotted Klein bottle. So I can see we
have three times the kind of mouth that
we find on the ordinary Klein bottle,
and it's just kind of hooked together in
such a way that it forms also a trefoil
knot. And so a knotted Klein bottle I
call a Klein knottle. And it's a perfectly
good Klein bottle.
- (Brady: Is it the magic one?)
No. It turns out this now brings
us back to
the ordinary Klein bottle. So it belongs
essentially to that shape. As a matter of
fact it's very hard to show that number
four because it really relies on the
fact that you need some colouring and you
need to distinguish the longitudinal
edges from the the cross side edges. In
the end it turned out to be rather
almost disappointingly simple. If you
take this Klein bottle right? We know we
could split it in the symmetry plane and
make two Möbius bands. One half might be
green the other one would be red, one is
right oriented or right twisting the
other one is left twisted. All you have
to do is switch colours, okay. Now if you
switch colours on the two Möbius bands
you get a Klein bottle that basically
seems to have the colour reversed. And
there's no way to deform it back into
the other one because they're
right-handed;
red band cannot be turned into
right-handed green band - but you
essentially need colours to find that
fourth Klein bottle. So finally that was
the answer. And it's all in the paper, I
didn't invent it I just made it
essentially visible to people; and so
that was my contribution there. I
actually had it peer-reviewed by those
mathematicians who wrote the original
paper and they loved it. They felt, yeah
I did
fair description of what they did and
absolutely it was needed to make a more
visible model to have a broader segment
of the pop- population actually
understand this, right? And so I may have
taken, you know, from 1 in 10,000
to 1 in
100 or whatever but that-
that's still an improvement.
[Preview] ...kind of cutting through
and I'm
rotating my knife
all the way around, and then doing it on
the other side; the doughnut
will still fall
apart into two individual pieces.